[MUSIC PLAYING]
The philosopher Timothy Leary
had some wildly utopian ideas
about what could be made
possible with the computer
revolution and the internet and
the communications revolution
that transpired thereafter.
And he used to say
that we can actually
use these tools to
upgrade our consciousness,
to electrify our thoughts
so that our memes could
travel at the speed of
light and spray eyeballs
through the screen and
lead to altered states
of consciousness, spaces
of ecstatic illumination
so that we could
use our technology
to upgrade the mind of mankind.
And who knows if
that might happen?
We're moving now towards what
people refer to as a sharing
economy, where people can
tweet and share and upload
and repurpose and
reconstitute and recombine
ideas in ways that they
never could before.
Of course, it calls into
question things like copyright,
things like how to
tag original work.
What makes something
original when
it can be so easily
transformed and reconceived.
Does that make it something new?
Is everything a remix
of what came before,
as Kirby Ferguson says?
Or are we just
moving into a space
where people can borrow,
steal, and repurpose
without giving due credit?
I mean, technology's always
been a double-edged sword.
It extends, but
it also amputates,
as Marshall McLuhan used to say.
It also opens up new
possibility spaces
for human expression, for human
dialogue, for human engagement.
This communication
revolution has always
been about extending our
capacity in both directions.
And it's up to us
to see how we use
these new tools to transform who
we are into what we might be.